heat up your gazpacho you want me to
heat up your gazpacho and prepare for a
10-minute compilation of michael stilber
getting mad
because we have showtime's latest drama
thriller starring brian cranston and
it's pretty darn good
you're goddamn right in this video we'll
be taking a deep dive
into your honor it's tragic ending and
some of the hidden details that led
up to this moment including how one song
from mozart is the key to
understanding the entire season so while
you're covering up your son's murder
make sure to like and subscribe
because here we go the series's final
episode begins with michael desiedo
unsure of where his son adam is the last
we saw of him he was invited to meet his
girlfriend fia's father
jimmy baxter a notorious crime lord who
also happens to be the father of the boy
adam accidentally killed way back in
episode 1 but adam didn't end up going
to meet him he instead has been brooding
over the news that his dead mother had
cheated on his dad
a fact that was hidden from him by
michael and this is the main question
your honor
asks should you tell the truth even
though it may hurt those you love
and as we'll find out with this ending
the writers have a very clear
answer to this for 10 episodes michael
desiro has been hiding the truth
not only about his wife's infidelity but
covering up his son's murder of rocco
baxter it's ironic that a judge
someone who's supposed to hold the truth
above all else has so much disdain for
it but as long
as the truth gets out there
we're good and this all ties into
michael's character arc
throughout the season we see how michael
goes the extra mile to get to the truth
and by extra mile i mean that literally
michael is training to run a marathon
and runs to the house of famali jones
a woman on trial for allegedly selling
drugs whose fate rests in the testimony
of a racist cop
michael so believes in getting to the
truth that he checks the house himself
to see if the witness's testimony
matches what's there in reality michael
is a good man who believes in
justice and the truth however as his
journey continues throughout the season
we'll see him turning into the opposite
a man who delivers injustice and has
disdain for the truth this shift results
in a tragic ending for him the worst
ending for this character the death of
his son who he tried
all season to save in this way the
writers are answering the question they
posited
in episode 1 withholding the truth leads
to more pain
in writing for film and television
there's often a scene where the
protagonist has
one final chance at redemption one final
chance to turn
away from what he or she has become and
right his or her wrongs
in your honor this scene for michael
occurs when he's confronted by his love
interest and former clerk
lee delemere she's found about the
murder cover-up and wants him to turn
himself in this is about
justice justice
down there they don't survive
kofi didn't adam won't if michael tells
the truth he'd be condemning his son to
die
am i a bad person because i value my own
life
so much less than the life of my child
everything michael has done
has been for his son and he's lost sight
of the fact that his decisions have led
to considerable pain and death family
jones and her three children including
kofi
are dead because of him not to mention
trevor the guy who tried to blackmail
michael who ended up getting shot by
jimmy michael has done
terrible things to protect his son and
in this way he kind of becomes like the
series's main antagonist
jimmy baxter michael is capable of going
against all the values he once held dear
to protect his son
and lee tells michael what he has to do
in order to cleanse his soul
do the right thing by convicting carlo
baxter for murdering kofi jones
and maybe his soul will get a second
chance and you're so
it's a second chance michael is really
manipulative
in this scene holding up the phone for
lee to call detective costello on him
but telling her if she does
she'd be condemning his son to die he
even throws a curveball to her telling
her he loves her
but lee isn't having it you can't have
me
you can't ever have me now so michael
has this chance of redemption but he
doesn't take it and this is when i knew
the story had to end in tragedy and i'll
get more into how this ties into the
shawshank redemption and mozart in a bit
so carlo ends up getting off for murder
adam gets a girlfriend and accepted into
nyu
and everything seems to go back for
michael basically all the bad guys face
no repercussions for what they did that
is until the show's final act
celebrating carlo's verdict fia invites
adam to meet her dad and come to their
party at the hotel
she doesn't know that adam was the one
to kill her brother however earlier that
day when jimmy went to console his wife
during the court case
he notices adam using an inhaler the
same object found at the scene of his
son's death
up until this point he thought michael
had been the one to hit and run his son
but now he knows he was just covering
for adam michael gets a call from
jimmy basically implying he's going to
kill his son so he tries to get in his
car but it's blocked by a truck good
thing he's been practicing for a
marathon because he has to run the
entire way downtown
where he's not let in by the hotel's
bouncers so this is just more evidence
of all these
tiny sequences of events lining up
perfectly to reach this
ending you never know when
life is gonna line up just perfectly
and walk you right into your future
michael has to watch through the window
as
jimmy hugs his son unsure of what's
going to happen when suddenly eugene the
half-brother of kofi jones
seeking revenge fires at carlo but
misses and hits adam and the irony here
is insane adam who accidentally killed
someone and ran away is killed by
someone by accident who also runs
away not only that he's killed by a gun
which was paid for by his own father
well indirectly eugene had his
autographed baseball he gave to lee and
michael bought it from her so it's
highly intimated that this money was
used so he could purchase a gun in the
commotion
michael is able to hold his dying son
howling in pain and grief this is just
like the story michael told adam about
the night his mother died
adam howled in michael's arms until he
fell asleep
only this time it's michael who's
howling and his son is now
asleep for good the series ends with
mozart's solaria from his opera the
marriage of figaro playing in the
background this is the same piece played
at the end of episode 1 where michael
and adam watch the shawshank redemption
together in the shawshank redemption
this song is played when andy dufresne
takes a hold of the speaker system
and blasts it for all the prisoners to
hear red played by morgan freeman
says in a voiceover about the song i
have no idea to this day what those two
italian ladies were singing about
truth is i don't want to know i like to
think they were singing about something
so beautiful it can't be expressed in
words
the irony here is that the song has
nothing to do with beauty instead it's
about two women writing a letter which
could
expose one of the characters infidelity
it was andy dufresne's wife's infidelity
that landed him in jail and it was
michael's wife's infidelity that led to
her death and the entire events of this
season
although not explicitly stated in the
show it's implied that michael's wife
robin was seeing one of her subjects
from the lower ninth ward an area where
she liked to photograph
it's there she was killed in an event
which if it had never taken place
adam would never have been there on her
anniversary and killed rocco whereas
andy achieves redemption
in his story michael does not he has
lost the very thing he spent the entire
season
trying to save now you might be asking
yourselves will there be a second season
there are still a number of unanswered
questions like is adam really
dead what happened to eugene and what
will happen between
jimmy and michael we do know that from
the beginning your honor was listed as a
limited series and creator peter moffatt
has said the show was written as a
one-off
although he's often wondered what
episode 11 would look like
that's not to say it can't return since
the israeli series the show is based off
was renewed for a second season with 10
more episodes
so there's definitely the possibility of
it coming back and like cranston's
previous series breaking
bad this show has steadily grown in
popularity with word of mouth
but what did you think of your honor i
want to hear your thoughts and theories
below
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can always follow me on
twitter and instagram
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much